all right so this is a Q&A it's pretty
informal if nobody has questions I guess
I'll just start talking more I'll just
talk more about any number of things but
so happy to talk about anything talk
talk about what we're doing at Quonset
happy to talk about open teams have you
talked about Python have you talked
about that part of the ecosystem them
focus I've been kind of my life has been
a journey when I was young
starting scifi I loved doing open source
development I loved working with the
community
I loved sharing code I loved having
feedback on that code love the
conversations but I also didn't know how
it's gonna pay for my kids I had three
kids already I have six now and they're
more expensive now because they're in
college when they were younger they were
also expensive but we could get by on
18,000 a year in Minnesota couldn't do
that in Austin did that in Rochester
Minnesota and and I knew already the
time that by giving my software how was
gonna make money so I already had that I
have had that question the whole time so
a lot of people complain they talk about
today oh hey we're not getting funded
I'm burned out I don't know there's no
money in open source
I'm like yeah that's if you just if you
don't have a way if you don't have a job
you have an agreement if you have a way
to get money you might end up doing a
lot of stuff that you'll get paid now
I've been really grateful that a lot of
good things still happen if you don't
get money you do get communities get
friends you get the opportunity to kind
of you get the opportunities get the
opportunity to go talk to people so well
you know numpy hasn't directly made me
anything I haven't made any money
directly off of numpy I wrote a book
that raised end up selling 3,000 copies
so I guess $90,000 from that book
roughly and about 60,000 of that went to
fund a graduate student of mine that he
was my one PhD student I graduated so
and then numb PI's also helped me get
conversations it's opened the door so
you go talk to people but then talking
to people means have to sell them
something else because they can't sell
the numpy already have that but I can
sell them training I can sell them
support I can sell them new things I can
sell them we work so that's a it's been
a constant question of how do we
actually help get we get the benefit of
open source but also
somehow connect online incentives so
that all the the value that's captured
from open-source by others doesn't just
only go to those people that build stuff
on top because they that's the situation
today what happens is Amazon makes a ton
of money off of Linux and off of the
open source they do they've they've
commercialized it but a lot of other
companies have - a lot of hedge funds a
lot of financial firms a lot of people
are making a lot of money using numpy
using sigh potti using pandas using
jupiter very little of that comes back
to support those projects it's a major
problem it's actually it's it's broken
like it won't work that way because
ultimately part of the challenges is it
is a generational problem because
whereas I could you know the promise of
doing this is great I'm looking today
going can I tell somebody go work on
open source and hope that you might have
be able to support yourself this
certainly it's difficult when venture
funds are out there pulling people in
and telling them I'll give you all this
money to work on a new thing but yet
open-source is still the best way to
produce infrastructure software it's not
the best way I don't think to produce
products like end-user products if you
think about end-user products income to
benefits there's trade-offs for open
source what open source does well what
commercial products do well and then I
kind of had the chance to actually get
in the bowels of both of that and
understand those differences very well
the difference between how I'm gonna
build a an end user facing product I
don't really need a community of people
and a community of voices telling me
what the user experience should be
factor yeah that's that's the wrong
thing you really want a product that
solves a problem for somebody has to
have some amount of top-down design at
least product management that then
chooses what it should be and so that
the user ends up with the thing that
it's not just the cacophony of features
that they don't understand how to use on
the other hand libraries and
infrastructure definitely needs lots of
eyeballs lots of opinions lots of people
to make sure it supports all the
different use cases and that's much
better handled by open source so my
belief I'm a big open source fan but I
love solutions as well so I believe
those solutions the software built on
open source needs help that's what open
teams is here to do open teams is to
help people that are building software
to sell it to are gonna use open source
as part of it those P they need to get
things out of open source you
connect with those over those
communities and talk to them more
efficiently and fund them I think
there's a very deep connection that we
made between people that need stop to
build and right now we're starting with
open source but really all of software
could be built is gonna be built this
way all of software is gonna need to see
I got features here I mean I need pieces
and open source I need things there so
we're trying to start the early stages
of starting that that that ecosystem so
so that's open teens this is one of the
major things we've spun out of con sites
our first spin out Quan site itself is a
is an incubation firm it's kind of
taking when I left anaconda epically
turned out at Connor over to Peter it's
sort of a and the rest of the group
there what I realized I wanted to do is
help a lot of other people create these
kind of scalable systems I want to want
to help people build companies that are
deeply connected to open-source
communities but provide value to the
world so that that's kind of what
venture firms do they do it but they do
it in a way that's not as cognizant of
open source they should be like most
venture firms I've talked a lot analysis
where we have a quant initiate as an
open source venture fund there's
actually one other that calls himself an
old boat adventure planets called OSS
capital then I've talked to a lot of
other venture firms and some of the most
intelligent of them they say well yeah
all software uses open source so of
course we understand we we worry about
that to say well great well do you
understand how to actually you should
probably be funding those open source
communities right maybe some of the
carried interest you earn on those on
those companies to invest in how about
someone that comes back to also the sort
the communities that you need to thrive
that's what we do so we have a venture
fund that directly supports open source
research as well so that's the big
picture like I've got all these little
things going but it's to support an
ecosystem and an open economy but the
direct thing so some of you might care
about this if you're a startup if you
want to create a startup if you're
thinking about green and startup you
want to fund this
let's talk I mean this is early stages
so we're still trying to raise our first
fund where we're just we're raising
money from LP is to raise this fund so
we don't have all the money in the bank
that we're trying to get but we're
working at it and we've already made
some investments so small early-stage
investments but we can help talk about
what it takes to build a company and
certainly happy to talk to you about
that
once a labs again
one of the organizations funded by
carried interest on the fund but also
funded by direct work community work
orders we call them this is contract
work that actually funds open source the
purpose of this is really to say we need
a pilot a core team I did is out there
but who's supporting matplotlib numpy
scifi anaconda has invested some
resources and funding pandas and and
scikit-learn and several other projects
but we need more we need lots of people
doing this and so Consulate Labs is an
example it's one of many research labs
it should exist I believe there should
be a thousand of these labs existing all
over associate all the kinds of
companies so there's more of an example
than intended to dominate the world but
we're gonna build a 50 to 75 person team
at quonset labs to fund and work on open
source so and to do that we do what we
have done for 12 years which is open
source consulting so kind of leveraging
that network and knowing how to do
open-source consulting that's what we do
but the goal is to do things like this
initiative you Python so alright I'll
prompt did some questions hopefully you
can then answer say you know please
answer I'd love to be directed by you
yeah yeah good question
all the way it depends on how important
python is to their operations right if
pythons kind of occasional thing they
use a little bit then it's really hard
to make a compelling argument support it
right but it's there if it's actually
critical to their workflow everybody has
a support everybody knows that
effectively when they when they've
bought a vendor when they partner with
somebody and they're investing in that
thing it's kind of a double-edged sword
because they're expecting certain things
out of that that capability everybody
understands that cutting the important
the point of maintenance and support on
that thing like you have yes you got
them for free but who's supporting it
you got the capability for free but
you've got to support it somehow how do
you do that well there's actually ways
to do that it's not just an amorphous
mass or people out there you can pay
money to that will
make sure that your needs and wants and
desires and effort and things you're
expecting out of that platform you can
get delivered so there's a risk there's
a risk mitigation and that's one Avenue
to take with so with the sea level is
they understand that notion they
understand oh yeah I have this risk now
risk is one of those things it's some
people take the risk we all do sometimes
we go beyond it's a risk but I'm going
to take it so okay but other times it's
like oh yeah we just made commitments to
these other people that we're going to
lose our shirt unless we have some way
to back it so that's one risk mitigation
the other is just cost savings you know
hey we have this initiative we're gonna
go build this thing you know if we built
that thing using if we just open source
could be tweaked a little bit then we
can build our thing on top and we could
save millions of dollars as opposed to
taking the existing open source and then
working around it and assuming what we
have so it's like you have if you assume
that the state of the world is what only
what's there now you end up building
from there you'll spend a lot more money
than if you recognized the state of the
world is malleable you can actually
efficiently fund open source communities
to get pieces you need done and now you
don't have to maintain that and then you
spend less money to build on top and
then you also spend less money
maintained in the future but that
requires some guidance right like
somebody has to do the work to figure
out where that correct what that correct
framing is what the correct way to
organize your software to do that is and
quants I can do that for the PI data
stack now if you're building on top of
another stack you know quants that may
not be the right place to do that but
there are other organizations that can
do that that can help you understand how
to help the open source grow while
saving yourself money so ro so basically
there's risk mitigation there's basic
ROI save cost savings you're going to
save money I think the other thing is
just features you know then the other
thing is hey we could make money selim
prove our customer experience and sell
more of whatever we're selling if we
have more features and these features
can come pretty cheaply by supporting
open source in these ways that make
sense
so you basically those are the kind of
three major areas that most c-level
people care about and you can address
all three of them and kind of what the
core story should be depends on the
situation
yeah go ahead so I have some of these
stories go correct 100% smaller
companies struggle to compel armies take
all kinds of risks and just deal with it
for example and then if you're too big
yeah I would actually say nobody's too
big like that I would say that's
actually many people think that way but
they don't realize that they're they're
not actually bigger than the world like
there is no company out there that's
bigger than the open-source community
like there aren't they aren't and and
furthermore no company and the reason
it's not because just size of people
it's about mindshare that's about my
chair so a good example for you as
goldman sachs like goldman sachs in the
70s and 80s
built a better version of the potato
sack then existed they built slang secti
b-beautiful system actually we don't yet
have we haven't yet actually replicated
all of what it does it's a really nice
system and they were content because
they had the best system in-house
everybody used it they use it internally
nobody else had it it's great so
fast-forward 25 years now people left
there said hey we need this capability
started and then say well look around
I'm in been around he'll use Python and
so several investment banks went out and
used Python to build essentially the
equivalent and then that so all of a
sudden you know fourths ten years later
twenty two decades later goldman sachs
is sitting there on this proprietary
database that now they're trying to hire
people nobody wants to learn their
proprietary language nobody wants to
learn that so they can't get talent
meanwhile the markets were moved so that
there's all kinds of people learning
Python and learning that for the same
kind of capabilities and it becomes a
point of I you know even though they
could own it in the past they can't own
the future and so in every company's
like that no matter who you are I mean
Google that's when there's a reason
Google took tensorflow and it made it
open source like they're actually trying
to do jujitsu move on you right i I'm
actually a little I don't like what
they're doing I mean I think there's I
like Google I like the technology but I
don't I think the approach they're
taking could you
some work because they're effectively
trying to own an open-source community
as opposed to to an offender they're
creating an ecosystem like a shelled hey
we're gonna create a planet and here's
our planet look around it's like a domed
planet as opposed to saying oh we're
gonna make the world as it exists better
and let it grow as far as it wants to go
so you know that's it that's you can't
actually do it even if your Disney went
too big yeah Peter go ahead Google feels
that way right now actually yeah he's
got a beer company in the me yes perfect
well-spoken - great job Peter thank you
it's exactly what I wanted or tapes that
people have made copies to see like
here's the like I attempted to get like
an accounting value of we hired this
person to work half their time working
source and this is how much we you know
how many dollars actual story that's a
great question what you know where are
these stories yeah is there a place you
can go to gather these stories because I
would say there I don't know of a single
place where you can go and look and find
them I mean you can Google
yeah there's work to be done
yeah exactly I would say to there enter
your question immediately I don't think
there is a great place for that I think
none focus could provide in there's an
opportunity to provide more of that
information that's one of the things we
care about a Quon site providing those
case studies find those use cases we
have to do a better job of it most of
time we have those anecdotal
conversations in person right but it's
awesome to have them localize somewhere
it's good suggestion part of the
challenge is some of these conversations
are hard to get permission like I can't
like I can't really tell the story of
Goldman Sachs and publicize it I have a
record of broadcast exactly well they've
told that story now too right so and you
know if it's recorded on PI data nobody
will watch it because there's so much
good content who's in who's gonna sign
in to this one little demon little thing
yeah watch this will be the one viral
video now
[Laughter]
a lot of bit larger more established
more conservative organizations they
just we always build it in-house we
always do you know it just buy something
that's a commercial product and so now
they're starting a condor as they bring
in more folks that want to use Python
and open-source products they realize
they're being forced to change
yeah it's it's it's my grinning but
there's a lot of those conversations
that still have a lot of them so you
know happy to help actually I'd love to
do it if you want to you know happiness
that's what we do that's what I do I go
and talk to people all the time about
their and then just really have a real
honest conversation with them with the
sea level about how do they how does
this help them right excellent this is
my short paragraph paper
exactly
it's totally fine if I really loved that
we worked on that a while with the SyFy
leading sci-fi published the Proceedings
published and Jo SS is a outgrowth of
that too a real formal Journal that
several people took forward and farther
I think it's really important like
understanding the current incentive
drivers that exist and instead of Union
what you can rail against them right you
know you can really get seeing the
windmills I like Don Quixote the book
too but ultimately you make change by
realigning like okay there's the state
of the world let's see what we can do to
take it where it is put something in
place that real lines incentives then
moves forward from here that to me
that's what open teams is we've got
another project you'll hear us talk
about a little bit called Pharaoh SS
Pharaoh assess is kind of a sister of
open teams you talked about alignment
like one of the things we want to do
about the open scene is also helping
with is credit reputation one of the
challenges open source right now is its
amorphous people make contributions and
it's not just the credit is not
distributed equally like people do get
credit I get lots of credit for numpy in
sci-fi but there's guy named Charles
Harris who's been in the Python
community the numpy community for 10
years really involved has kept it going
all during the time while I've been here
and there and trying to make get funding
for it and doing some work here and
there he's been there the whole time
right doesn't get as much credit I
didn't really want he's not he's not a
public speaker doesn't rely on the
public deserves tena credit right we
don't we don't it's not equally spread I
care about that a lot so it's one of the
reasons and it's an equivalent of
academic credit like reputation is
important
it is so how do we make open-source
something that's more gives more credit
so if you look at open teams its hold
its goal on the developer side it's got
several goals there but one is to help
projects govern better and and one way
they govern better is by actually
assigning credit to the actual
contributors like project governance has
several roles it's where direction of
the code direction the community we want
to help project organizers fulfill their
governance goals one of which is to
assign credit and make sure credit gets
goes to where credit's due because
that's not something you can automate
and I don't it's not an automated tool
it's you can do things to provide tools
to help that but ultimately someone's
got to make a decision about ok or who
did this work and what when was it
valuable right because that's the key
part that isn't automatable yet so
that's one thing open teams does to fair
OSS is about setting up a credit like
giving people credit for for supporting
open source like a place it kind of it's
a brand and it's a long-term goal of
mine it's not actually an active thing
right now we're not out promoting it
much we'll see it here and they're like
open teams is gonna be giving away
shares you know in fair OSS the purpose
of fair OSS is to be a watchdog holding
companies accountable for giving back to
open source that they rely on so it's
basically a brand they can get like LEED
certification like organic certified
like a brand they can get for doing
things like establishing revenue sharing
agreements and equity sharing agreements
what I realized last year is that all I
wanted when I wrote Sai PI from
businesses was some agreement that if
they benefit from Sify that some of
their benefit some of their growth in
their capitalization some of the growth
of their company some of the revenue
they earn would actually come back to
the project that's all I cared about
it's all I wanted if you know if they
people did that just to a tiny degree
actually the world would be a much
better place so you know but asking for
donations is hard like you got to have
some you gotta have some reason they do
it well there is a reason there's kind
of reason people get involved in
open-source today is because of you
currently developers manifestly go to
work for places that support open-source
more than places that don't so a lot of
companies are figured
now and they all are on the band we know
yeah we support open source because
that's how they get hired the best
talent and they know that yeah yeah yeah
it's interesting I mean sources are
certainly a mechanism as well and I'm
really advocating all of those
mechanisms right every night I can't do
them all like but I've run trying to
encourage other people like hey there's
a lot we can do and I think that's
aspera fact I Fernando Paris has a great
statement he calls the funding fabric
that's why I look at this - it's not
gonna be one thing that dominates and
wins it's the fact there's a funding
fabric and lots of ways because
open-source is frankly massive that's
what surprised me actually do it's a
market research for open teams realizing
oh my goodness you know depend on who
you look at it's either 97% or 99% the
same 99% of software already uses open
source so this is a problem you don't
know you have I mean it's one of the
marketing terms we tell companies as
well look we're helping you solve the
biggest problem you know you have which
is you're totally rely on an open source
and you're totally not taking care of it
you're totally not doing anything to
support it so guess what those wins can
change all of a sudden you're using
numpy today and you know a couple things
happen and pretty soon everybody's over
on pi torch and your codebase is stuck
over here in the past and you have no
way forward and you could have avoided
that but actually having a relationship
with the community to help them and help
help them help you so that's these are
real problems that exists and they're
going to start biting people what I'm
trying to avoid I don't want to have
that happen be open source socks we
should never do open source I think
fortunately that's we're past that you
know that's something that could have
happened 10 years ago but we're past
that people because it's it's it's
ubiquitous it's everywhere there's
like but they could say I shouldn't use
that project maybe and that's what it'll
be 97 percent 99 percent used
open-source 57 percent like I think
that's too much that's too much
precision let's say 60 percent 60 half
this 1/2 half of the code out there is
open-source already what should it be it
won't be hundred percent their advocates
out there say all coaches open source
I'm not one of them I actually think
that's naive and doesn't recognize the
problem that the issue that software
solves pain points and there are pain
points out there that it's best to
actually use proprietary software to
solve that a community is not gonna
support you're not gonna be able to
create open-source there's no value in
the open-source ecosystem of making an
open-source that's an argument I have
with people some people are all open
sort of all sawfish building source I'm
not one of those people but I think 75%
probably more than 50 percent partner X
75 maybe seen an 80 data order will be
open source and just that that little
thin layer on top like the atmosphere
keeps the earth you know we're gonna
live here tiny little thin layer
there'll be a thin layer of proprietary
software that ensures the open source
ecosystem can thrive and the goal is
just make that feedback tunnel so the
proprietary software using open source
actually formally connects back to
support the open source ecosystem that's
the work we still have to do that is not
out there currently we have effectively
a exploitation device a lot of people
can build proprietary software it's hard
to do that one thing to keep in mind
though as you're thinking about that
it's not a ton of percent like having
built company realizing how expensive it
is just to get a product off the ground
and hired and button and then the sales
and marketing team the effort around it
like if you can get 1/2 percent of the
your money back to open-source that's
the goal it's not 10 it's not 20 it's
not 50 it's like being a my thinking is
like honestly if it was half a percent
However percent would do everything and
it's it's totally doable it's totally
doable just a matter of yeah there's
hiring dollars are being spent that we
spent more efficiently there's marketing
dollars being spent that we spend more
efficiency efficiently there's there's
software dollars are being spent on
expensive writing that pressure a
software we spent more efficiently so
there's the market opportunity we have
to go find out how to kind of capture
that and pull it back towards
open-source software that's the mission
I'm that's the real Ethne mission I'm on
now it's how do we do that and to do
that we you know I still we thought
for initiatives we have things we're
trying to produce B pythons just one of
them we've got a high-level data sight
we had something called open tensors
it's just a there won't be a package
called open tensors there'll be a
concept the concept is we have to build
high level API is for data frames arrays
and data types
right now there's date of data frames
are everywhere and they're exploding and
people are using them to build libraries
on top but which library do you use use
which API do you use if am using numpy
no use the whole numpy api or what is
the api i can use that allows me to
write tools like side power socket learn
on top but let the implementation of the
array migrate to GPUs other kinds of
runtime features that doesn't exist
right now and it's it's a problem that's
another area this is our big important
problem have to fix so there's lots to
do but we gotta get funny to do it and
there's ways to get that funding yeah
what do you see is the recourse to try
to encourage it's good question I mean
at the end of the day the first order
bit is to solve your problem right and
that's everybody that's true for
everybody like Maslow's hierarchy
Maslow's law Harkey of needs you've got
to solve your problem and tensile fluff
solves the problems we people use it I
think the second order bid is is solved
my future problem right solve a problem
that doesn't don't dig a hole on solving
my problem so I'm that second order is
where you can look it was where I look
and say hey that you're solving this
problem you're doing in a way that's
actually digging a hole and not helping
this broader problem I think what you do
is you use alternatives you go okay
actually pipe torch solves this problem
- and is a bit more community oriented
and you tell Google why now I will say
tensorflow has a community around the
core that's actually a reasonable
open-source community like they are
doing a good job of creating community
around their core just the core itself
is there's challenges with how how it
with it with Billy map it's a big
problem and they're doing a lot of great
work so I'm not I'm not here to bash
Google right I would actually say thank
you google right his might be my big
message because they're doing a lot of
good work
enjoy the the way that they'll
open-sourced in the way because it seems
like there's I think I think I think PI
torch is doing a good job right I think
there but I also recognize the different
business situation that Google has
versus Facebook in their course so I
don't but I do like their approach
they're taking which is much more
heycome anybody can contribute to PI
torch they have an open slack slack
channel not saying that that's exactly
the way to have an open channel but it
is open anybody can join people make
contributions to Facebook I think
they're inclusive and that contributions
you're not limited by to contribute to
Pi torch based on where you work it's
just simply how much you know and can
you if can you spend the time I like
that
I think the the product SantaCon is put
out right the way that bokade ask you
know think about the Wade ask emerge
tried ask was company backed and it kind
of spent a lot of money building tasks
right we got some funding from DARPA to
do it we spent a lot of money internally
the building task spotting or paying for
people giving people jobs talking about
it and at length then task was company
back but then it became community lead
and from the beginning it was very much
open hey come contribute come join
anybody can become a member anybody can
contribute very open in its cooperation
model and then ultimately becoming an
unfocus sponsored project when it got
enough community that it could be more
than just anaconda backing it so but I
also there is room in the world for
company backed open source there is and
I think we should as a community should
be tolerant of company backed open
source and recognize and really just
help companies make the decision of why
they should be company backed and kind
of so tensor flows company back which
can have an impact the challenge there
the challenge was tensorflow is they're
coming into a world that already exists
where there's already community because
systems that they're intersecting with
like I wouldn't have any problem with
tensorflow with some entirely new and
there are things there that are entirely
new but if they were adapting to what
was was instead of replacing what is I'd
be more satisfied more happy but they're
kind of coming in with a new array
object with a new concept of what a
tensor means on a rate and in the array
is like numpy exists array objects have
existed in Python workflows array
workflows work I he was listed in Python
for many years and we just need GPU
support and
automatic differentiation to do machine
learning didn't need an entire new C++
infrastructure right that's that's the
the challenge so work with the community
to modify the project that meets your
needs
you actually have saved him a lot of
money they spent a lot of money that
they would didn't really need asset
spend so that's that's that's kind of
what I mean so yeah yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely that's where the rubber hits
the road and there's a lot of approaches
to take there it depends most are very
willing to make sure that changes the
open-source stay an open-source you
typically have to be intentional to have
the conversation with their procurement
legal department because their default
agreements don't do that
so you basically modify this clause so
it actually changes to the open-source
go back to open-source oh yeah that's
fine they don't mind it's just they're
not predisposed that way so I think
that's one great initiative is the fact
we should share legal documents legal
paragraphs to put to make sure your your
statement of work includes countries
backed open-source but they're
appropriately concerned they don't want
all the stuff you're doing to be
open-source and that's fine you're not
saying that all has to be you're just
saying the pieces you want it's a really
easy sell actually once they understand
oh did you want to maintain this
yourself like these changes we made to
numpy you want to fork that into a your
private repo you maintain yourself oh no
no no no okay well then this is that you
just help them understand the
consequence their decisions because they
don't typically want that so it's it's
it ten years ago that was hard
conversation it's very easy today I
would say yeah
[Music]
there's no support for it yeah yes I
would say that's that's exactly the risk
you need to let people understand and
then the solution is you can actually
that's what's one powerful opportunity
for these research labs consulting
companies like what I'm doing at Quonset
I feel can be replicated a thousandfold
around the world
I don't think and it's what we've been
doing for a while but you have but and
for product like that I would say it's
they're they're desperately needing that
they need somebody to stand up and say
yes this is a supported tool so I think
it's an opportunity actually I would
look at that and say hey there's even
better Oh
the challenge with numpy is actually not
the there's people out there willing to
support it the challenge with numpy is
actually enough funding to really
organize the governance so that
agreements can happen it's in it and
then fortunately the grant that Sloane
gave has provided some of that so that
it's been able to move forward a bit
more quantitating people to work in that
space so the conversation can move
forward it's a different problem there
but that's a great opportunity let's
talk and I can will this help you set
them up so you can actually support that
in a way that is honors the people that
wrote the code and make sure that
anybody can come to the table in a way
that makes it community-led and set a
company back
for writing it for creating new yeah I
agree that's a whole question about it's
also related to funding
like most grant problems today is you
cannot get a grant to maintain software
you get a grant to write something new
but maintaining software is really
difficult not that needs to change
somehow or we need at least create some
mechanism so maintaining what exists can
be written into grants there's work
ahead like that's a that's a lot work
yeah absolutely
yeah fair enough fair enough so and I
know we're out of time but go and set up
an open teams help us build this
community it's easy to just collect your
github account or your get lab account
either one to your open teams identity
and just start sharing credit nominating
people for what they did the bond the
projects if a project you're working on
isn't there get it signed up get the
project leaders on board right now
there's ability to give credit assign
credit and how many people what they've
done build your profile for hey I'm done
open source like this this is my point
I'm encouraging everybody to do that
it's a place it's a place we look for at
one site one of the managing partners
open team is also getting more managing
partner if you're an organization that
wants to do work with open source sign
up if you want to be able to fund
projects you see on the platform if you
want to be able to produce an initiative
say hey I have an idea for something we
ought to be doing great I thought it was
running right now Eunice is here a lot
of what we have to do still is self
driven what you can do now what you can
do now is nominate people create your
organization create your profile we're
adding tools belove create initiatives
modify initiatives do voting polling on
initiatives to connect with the projects
to make sure the where the initiatives
going has feedback from the community
it's one of the key challenges is how do
you actually do work that isn't just
people aren't really two antibodies
against they're actually supportive of
at least to some degree so not
information needs to be out there if
you're a funder and somebody proposes
something you want to know well do
people care about this says you
information from the rest of the
community about this they want to know
that well how do you do that so open
teams can help generate that information
for you to actually improve those calls
yep
providing some detail about what you did
thank you for mentioning that that's a
huge deal actually how I use it you
don't have to have contribute in these
projects but if you use them let people
know that helps the maintainer z' helps
funders the goal is to really create a
rich fabric or rich ecosystem that
information can flow so these funding
fabric this funding ecosystem can also
grow along the lines it already works we
don't have to reinvent many things but
just educate tweak help move things
forward
alright thanks I'd love to talk about
this stuff have you talked at any time
about funding and getting open source
community we have an open teams
community its whole goal is to talk
about funding and open source so come be
a part of the community here in Austin
it's a sister community to the PI data
community
we're very we worked very closely with
num focused we love them so happy to
keep talking about everything Thanks
[Applause]